it was just a matter of time until one
of the most like trailers on youtube was
recreated in Grand Theft Auto 5
battlefield ones popular trailer has
gotten the GTA treatment from youtube
user j57 f the world war one setting has
been swapped out for Los Santos as you'd
expect the set pieces don't quite fit
what happened in the battlefield one
trailer but you have to give credit to
j57 f for the accuracy given what he had
to work with this isn't the first time
we've seen a trailer recreated in GTA 5
James Bond metal gear solid 5 and even
the Teletubbies all got the same
treatment in case you missed it the
battlefield one announcement trailer has
gotten some significant attention since
it's revealed last week it's been liked
over 1 million times on YouTube and even
the developers of Call of Duty infinite
warfare have praised it Infinity Ward
posted on Facebook it's a great reveal
trailer kudos to the dice team
battlefield one is set to release on the
playstation 4 xbox one and pc on october
21st for more on battlefield one
including a behind-closed-doors
impression head on over to gamespot com